[Music]
blade smith's congratulations you've
made it to the final round of this
competition now it's time to send you
back to your home forges to recreate
this iconic weapon from history
the boar sword
good luck we'll see you in four days
good job man
[Music]
so it's day one excited to get to work
on this boar sword ready to knock it out
i've never made anything this big it's
gonna be an interesting build swinging
this four pound sledge is getting heavy
already
[Music]
my game plan for today is to get at
least half of the sword forged out i
want to get those curves established
it's definitely interesting hammering
those waves in there because the blade
will want to walk sideways
and so
having to bring it back to establish
that edge-to-head straightness it's
difficult i was hoping to be able to get
a little bit farther along than what i
did but uh i think it's going pretty
well
a bit of a uh geometry dilemma here and
then
i'm hitting the ceiling before i can hit
the blade on the grinder so i'm gonna
have to
either take some extra wood out here
make it cut out here
i can't underestimate the size of this
blade i got to be really careful while
i'm trying to grind it in my tiny little
shop perfect
so after cutting away a bit of the table
and a bit of the roof it seems to be
working now
so just finished forging up the crossbar
so it's time to quench if this goes well
i'll be set up really well for the rest
of this competition it goes poorly the
opposite this crossbar is making it a
lot
more difficult than i was anticipating
to get this whole blade hot fortunately
it should be okay still
here we go
that's the sound i wanted to hear
[Music]
today i hope to accomplish the heat
treat this is the biggest thing i've
ever heat treated
i've got a forge that i'm borrowing from
a buddy of mine it's a five burner forge
and it's normally laid down you know
laying perpendicular i've got it
standing up and so uh this is the first
time i i've used it in this fashion i
hope it works for me
i'm gonna take my forge and set up
underneath that way
i get a normal heat treat all the way
from the blade tip to the tang this heat
treat process is the most critical part
if you don't have the heat treat
processed down right then all you have
is a blade shaped object yeah and it's
not gonna stay sharp so i gotta get this
heat treat done it has to happen today
it's go time if it doesn't go right i
don't know what i'm gonna do
i do have a slight warp
we're good
i'm out of the woods but still have some
work to do
i was tempering last night with a torch
and
screwed the pooch a little bit and got
way too hot on my blade so i've lost a
lot of hardness and i'm gonna have to
re-quench
never done a torch tempering before and
i guess that's what i get for my lack of
experience
a second quench is just
additional risk every time you quench
there's a risk of extra warping of a
crack a broken blade it is quite a
setback
if this quench fails i may be forced to
start over from scratch here we go
it's definitely hard disaster averted
for now so long as i can get the
tempering ride on my second try
this time around i'm gonna be really
slow really careful and i've got my heat
gun right here pointing at this blade
the whole time if it goes above 350
degrees i'm gonna immediately pull the
torch and make sure that i don't over
temper this blade again
the deed is done this should be a strong
hard blade now
i'm going to move forward put a handle
on this polish it up and turn it into
the judges
it's the start of the last day it's
raining like a cow pissing on a flat
rock outside so we're working on the
handle and the pommel and just a little
bit of cleanup and sharpening and
we're done
now i'm gonna go into shaping
that feels good and balanced right there
the farther along i got in this build
the more confident i became in the
weapon i didn't have enough time to test
it but uh i'm i'm confident that it'll
pass
ladies and gentlemen
a bore sword
all right bladesmiths to test the
lethality of your bore swords i will
deliver thrusts and cuts on this more
carcass
john you're first you ready for this
absolutely
you
[Music]
all right john first up i like the
balance i like that i can put two hands
in it it's all void enough to where i
can hold on and i can tell where the
edge is and when we're pushing and
thrusting as it's meant to be
the tip is sharp enough to thrust all
the way through your edges as you can
see
are sharp enough to cut pieces out of
this poor carcass overall sir
it'll kill
thanks sir congrats
thanks man all right isaac your turn are
you ready for this let's make some bacon
[Music]
[Music]
all right isaac first up it's much
lighter
so it's easier to control when you're
moving with the blade
and as you can see when i was thrusting
in there the point you have here the
edges are very sharp it thrusts all the
way in and even when it hits bone
it's got a very good flex to it do not
pick up a pen
overall sir
your boar sword
will make bacon and keel
thank you
gentlemen it's time for the strength
test the sheet metal stab
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades i'll be
stabbing into the sheet metal but this
test is not about what your blades do to
that target it's about what that target
does to your blades jonathan you're here
first you ready absolutely
[Music]
all right jonathan
your blade is still sharp pretty much
all the way to the tip now the tip did
get flattened a little bit but that was
a very very acute tip that you had on
there all in all it's a comfortable
weapon
it's certainly held up beautifully
nice and done thank you
all right isaac are you ready for this
as ready as i'm gonna be
there's definitely a significant bend
all right there's a good flex in your
blade which we saw in an earlier test
but when you quench this blade i'm
assuming right in here somewhere was
where that quench stopped
so
this is not really solid right here
you did lose your tip up here but your
edges held up it's still sharp but you
can just see there's an obvious
issue with that bend there all right
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
to find out if there's any sharpness
left on your tip and edges i will take
your weapon and stab and slash at this
deer hide now unlike the strength test
this is all about what your blade will
do to this deer height john you're first
you ready for this let's do it
[Music]
all right john
looking at the tip here i can see where
it flattened out took a little bit of
effort to be able to puncture through
but it did
your edges are still sharp the cuts are
clean
overall sir
you have a cut thanks sir all right i
suck your turn sir are you ready i am
[Music]
that's about what i expected
i straightened it
oh did you
the damage to your tip on the strength
that's really took it out there is no
tip to this anymore i can put my finger
on that but the edge of your blade on
both sides as you can see cut all the
way through
now the interesting thing to note is
that all that bending actually
straightened your blade
overall sir
bit of a cut
thank you
bladesmiths the judges have deliberated
right here on the forge floor they've
made their final decision
isaac your blade didn't make the cut
your blade took a bend in the strength
test and for that reason i have to ask
you to please leave the forge
[Music]
the end i'll be all of this test was the
fact that i couldn't get a full heat
treat all the way up and down my blade
and that's what sent me home i made it
to second place and regardless of the
results of this whole thing it's been
the best birthday present i've ever
gotten
well jonathan it would appear that
warrior ethos runs deep in you because
not only are you an active duty marine
you are also the forged and fire
champion that's a title that comes with
a check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
being fortune fired champion it feels
great
good job it's a boost of confidence it's
not the big things that really matter
it's the little things the attention to
detail that make a big difference
you